All right.
April. It is Monday, October 26, 2020.
We are eight days from the election from the day that we'll
decide the fate of humanity, eight freaking days, people, here we go.
All right. I normally don't do direct messages on Mondays and Fridays. However,
I'm doing a mini one right now.
Then we're going to do our regular shows Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday,
and then we're going to do another one on Friday because obviously this week is
going to be, as I like to say, bananas,
it's going to be ultra bananas this week, obviously.
And then I can only imagine what's going to happen into the weekend and Monday
and Tuesday. And then once their election results, aren't accepted,
then you know, the next couple of years and all that, but, well,
one thing at a time let's just deal with today as it is.
So I'm doing just a quick show today where I'm just going to show you two clips,
uh, that the mainstream media won't show you.
You are obviously not going to see these on CNN.
You're not going to see them on ABC, NBC, CBS, or anywhere else,
but these are on fire online.
And when I talk about the reality war,
the fact that whether you watch online stuff or mainstream
stuff and which online stuff and mainstream stuff, you watch,
you live in it actually different reality at this point,
then people who consume other things. I think that if you're watching this,
your reality is somewhat similar to mine.
And I think we've got a pretty decent grasp on reality over here, but, but even,
even I'm going to have my blind spots, but I thought that these two clips,
which are so indicative of something that's happening right now,
that the mainstream won't talk about were important to show.
So this first clip that we're going to throw to this is, uh, Joe Biden,
forgetting who he's running against.
This is the most consequent,
not because I'm running it because who I'm running against this,
the most consequential election, uh, and, uh, and a long, long, long time.
And the character of the country in my view is literally on the ballot.
What kind of country we're going to be four more years of Georgia, Georgia.
He, uh, he's going to find ourselves in a position where if, uh,
Trump gets elected, uh, we're going to be, uh,
we're going to be in a different world. And, um, and so.
All right, glibness and sarcasm and humor aside.
Um, I feel bad for the sign language lady,
because what was she supposed to do in the middle of that? All right,
that wasn't glibness aside. Um, this is seriously depressing.
Joe Biden has obviously the early onset, early stages of dementia.
And not only is nobody saying anything about it,
they're actively using him and go back,
rewind the clip for 20 seconds from now and watch Jill bite.
And she mouths Trump twice to him. She, she, this is elder abuse. I mean,
she is abusing her husband and using him to attain power.
That's what all of the DNC people are.
That's what everyone who's supporting Joe Biden doing. They are,
they are using this person who obviously is not capable,
who has serious cognitive that it's miraculous. Yes.
I know what a bunch of you are going to say,
especially if you're more mainstream media type people, you're going to say, Oh,
but during the debates, he seems lucid. He seems cognizant. Yes, that's right.
They put him somewhere for four days. They shut him down.
I don't know if he's sleeping the entire time.
And then they have him snort some Adderall, or God knows what they're doing.
Something is not right.
And you only see it if you pay attention to the news online.
And for now our ability to trade clips on YouTube and Twitter and everywhere
else, but who knows how much longer we'll have that ability. It's just,
I thought it was important to show that because this isn't just like some little
verbal gaffe, we all make verbal gaps. I speak live to a camera all the time.
I'm going to screw up a word here and there.
You're going to screw up a date or get, you know, forget something.
All of those things, like all of that is totally legit.
The man running for president literally could not remember the name of
his opponent, who happens to be the current president of the United States.
Okay. That is a problem,
but you're not going to see it on CNN and you're not going to see it anywhere
else. And I thought it was just worth just there it is.
There it's for you to decide, don't even listen to anything I'm saying about it.
Does that seem right to you? Yes or no. I guess that's the real question.
And then there was another clip going, making the rounds this weekend,
another one to buy it in. And by the way, before I even play this one,
I should say, that's not to say Trump,
doesn't say some funny things and odd things. And he has a strange way,
you know,
he starts talking and then he interrupts himself and then he kind of gets back
and reverses him. Cause he's doing a lot of stream of conscious stuff. Um,
which you know, that that's fine. It's partly what I do here. Right?
Like I don't really write much down.
I scribbled down a few things before we start.
And then I just talked to you and sometimes you got a lot of thoughts in your
head and you want to get to them and, and all that.
And I find that also as an interviewer, that's actually kind of fun.
When you see a guest who's really off, off the cuff,
who's really exploring the stuff with you because they're not going into
pre-packaged things. But when you're truly off the cuff,
you might be a little more prone to mistakes and things like that.
That that's okay. Right.
Or you might be a little more prone to too.
You're getting what you're saying. So there were times one more thing.
Then I'll get to this Biden clip. There were times when I was on tour with, uh,
Jordan Peterson and I would moderate the Q and a at the end.
So we do about 45 minutes of Q and a.
This is after he's given an hour and a half lecture. We've traveled that day.
He's done a ton of interviews, blah, blah, blah. And at the end,
I'd be asking questions that were from the crowd.
Usually I'd pepper in some of my own questions. And he'd go on a long,
long tangent on somebody else's question.
And it's like 12 minutes later and I'm trying to listen to him so that I can
then, you know, twist it into some other place that might be interesting. Right.
Could give it a little turn. That might be interesting for the crowd.
And then sometimes he would say, so what was the question? And I'd go, I'm not,
I'm not even sure. And I'd have the audience yell it again,
because if you're actually trying to listen, you might,
you might sort of forget some of this stuff. Okay. That's a total sidebar.
This next clip. Uh, this is just from the last couple of days. And, uh,
did Biden just admit something that we've all long suspected let's find out.
Secondly,
we're in a situation where we had put and you guys
did it for our administrators, the president Obama's administration,
before this, we have put together, I think the most
extensive and inclusive voter fraud
organization in the history of American politics.
All right. So let me just repeat that for, uh,
I'm going to just cut that Obama part. Cause that was a little sidebar there.
We have put together,
I think the most extensive and inclusive voter fraud
organization in the history of American politics. Now,
I don't think he meant to say that. Obviously.
I don't think he's admitting to a voting fraud organization.
Maybe there is a voting fraud organization and maybe it has something to do with
the DNC, but I don't even think he would know about that,
but I'm not even going conspiracy level here.
The point is that he said voter fraud organization,
and he didn't even know that he said it.
He might've meant to say voter registration organization or some other thing
like that. But it's the general confusion, the stammering, all of that stuff.
It's something it's not nothing. I,
my grandma had dementia. And when I was doing stand-up in New York,
I was usually working at night. So I had some of my days free.
And for about a year, I went off in several times a week to the doctor,
with her to various doctors actually. And I know what that's like,
the confusion, the repetition, sometimes the anger, all of those things.
I am not doing this again to be glib or,
or nonsensical or whatever. But the point is,
if your friends are voting for bided, your family members are voting,
providing, and they don't see this stuff.
Like the simple truth is you're voting for Kamala Harris or whatever the machine
is behind her. And let's not forget just, you know, what was it? Two weeks ago,
Pelosi was talking about the 25th amendment. I mean,
that will be the plan to get rid of an incapacitated incapacitated,
Joe Biden. Like that is that, is it this, if he wins,
he's going to go in a bunker they'll release statements every now and again,
and try to get him out there just in the, the bare minimum. And then,
and then they'll just get rid of him. And Jill Biden should be embarrassed and,
and everyone behind this whole thing, um, it's just,
it's just painful. Anyway. I had to show you those two things,
because otherwise they don't get, see, they don't get seen by people.
And then the reality war,
as I'm always talking about just gets ramped up even more.
So maybe share that with somebody that that's on the fence. And I don't know,
they can, they can make their own decision. All right, people, we got Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday shows this week,
then we're going to do a bonus show on Friday.
We may even do stuff over the weekend because obviously a lot's going to happen
this week. Get out there as you can see.
It's a little cool in Los Angeles today.
I'm wearing a flannel for the first time in God knows how long, uh,
get out there, get some fresh air, take a walk. Don't go crazy.
Tomorrow.